[Music]
trust me everything else in this video
should be way more interesting once you
watch the full short which is on the
corridor YouTube channel right now so go
check that out first and then come right
back here and resume from this point
nailed it
[Applause]
all right today is a big day because we
are doing the final day of
pre-production for a little short film
featuring Joel Haver it's all about a
digital double yeah the least
represented profession on the Hollywood
circuit abused rejected forgotten and
we're bringing them to life finally Joel
Haver is a Creator on YouTube a very
very talented comedic actor and Video
Creator and in talking about a
mockumentary style very dry set up to an
absolutely ridiculous idea he seems like
the the perfect puzzle piece for this
and so he's on board and excited so
he'll be here tomorrow and we have
basically one more day to get all the
pieces in place make sure that the tech
is working make sure that the locations
are scouted the script is tuned in the
the tech side of this is bringing that
PS1 PS2 graphical Joel Haver into the
real world for a three four minute piece
and he's in every shot it's a really
interesting situation because normally
when you're working with like motion
capture data or or CG you have a very
curated list of shots that you're gonna
get and in this in the mockumentary
fashion we want to let Joel do what he
does best and that's ad-libs so we want
to play with him we want him to Banter
and in doing so we're going to need
really long takes with a ton of motion
capture so if we can't find an efficient
workflow this idea will not work and Sam
Sam may have just done that we're
talking about the electric pajamas we're
going to stick with the tried and true
xn suits if we're only doing one actor I
think we can do this I think we can pull
this off I also happen to figure out the
full ins and outs of animating made of
humans with unreal what's it made a
human it's just basically a Universal
Character Creation thing it looks good
and it's compatible with tons of
Animation tools and I know how to use it
also there's an LOD slider level of
detail which makes it so you can go from
photorealistic all the way down to like
a four polygon head guy so I think we
can use that we can use the xn suits we
can do face capture we can use iclone to
do automatic lip sync and also what's
great is that we can just run huge takes
and if we're rendering it with an unreal
it's a footage Factory sure we can do
final tweaks later the point is is that
we'll have that underlying base footage
to edit with that's the promise with the
whole unreal workflow it's so fast that
you you know you only wait a day or two
after your shoot and suddenly now you've
turned all that CG VFX BS into usable
footage instead so you're you're editing
with your VFX rather than editing for
your VFX this all sounds great but I'm
gonna feel so much better going into
tomorrow like actually shooting with
Joel if we test it today we should we
should do one full test certainly so Sam
will you scan me I
[Music]
um
I didn't realize I was going to be doing
like the whole video for you guys
but it happens to be something I'm very
interested so I think our interests are
aligning I'll tell you what I'll tell
you what we did we did we kind of let
him in this man we pulled him in a
little bit I will humbly offer my
services for all the things that I know
how to do and I will come and I will
learn to fish with the fishing master if
you'll have me on the boat sir uh All
Aboard matey
it's not the Titanic this time but
survived
or the Britannic that's the one I was
thinking of all hail the potatoes oh
wait oh [ __ ]
damn it sank
there's so much stuff we haven't figured
yet that we're committing to for this
next three day shoot look let me just
you bring you an ounce of comfort
just make sure you know what the hell
you're shooting and directing and make
sure the script's good because
everything else from here on out I'm
pretty sure it's gonna work just fine
okay so right now we are entering the
first phase of our test of this Pipeline
and that is to ensure that we can get a
scan of Joel's head and convert that
into a meta human that we can use for
basically the entire duration of this
thing first things first though
I need you to clean up you know what I
mean just the thing is we need a clear
hairline you know we want as much of it
as possible so just like if you just get
your hair back I might have to I might
have to wax the whole thing I'll see you
in 10 minutes
do you have any hair products I could
use to just maybe run it back and just
keep it there
it's picture day I gotta make sure that
it's looking follow me crisp follow me
should I take my shoes and socks off
dude I am slick
I can just slip through any little
cracker crevice right now to slide on
grease on through I'm not going to pay
you anything I'm going to leave this is
like the stuff of nightmares ready watch
this oh that
no one wants out
yeah honestly man oh hey guys
all right looking great no way you look
like you're ready hey it's perfect
um oh wait isn't it sad how this is how
it will be remembered in 100 years he
said it said
polishing My Lens so it's as crisp as
possible it's very relaxed eyes open
Italian Zen this photo scan will be made
of Jordan look at this there's his head
we're gonna take this and run this
through the mesh to made a human plug-in
the goal is for me to show you a model
and be like oh that looks good
foreign
oh my gosh that's so much better than I
thought it would be I mean it's weird
looking at it it's like a living version
of myself that I'd like to meet but I
also don't want to so day one day one is
our big day we have Joel coming in the
studio oh Joel wouldn't you oh hey man
you look damaged yeah yeah I feel I feel
damaged we're gonna do the same process
that we did with Jordan in the test so
we're gonna start actually creating 3D
Jewel I'm excited to be Max payneified I
have never been photo scanned in my life
you just want to be completely still
it's going to take maybe about one to
two minutes
um as you can see I've got to polish my
lens it's something I do every time yep
I I was in it's kind of like meditation
or sensory deprivation you know you kind
of just let yourself go to it yeah yeah
your mind really starts going you're
like you start thinking about a lot of
things in that Silence of some of the
best and worst things of my life in
those two minutes which is really
painful memories and really happy
memories all at once we're gonna take
that photo scan of Joel's face we're
going to apply it to a metahuman whoa
I'd say it's pretty damn good oh
wow you need
that's why I looked like the day I was
born no freckles no no take those
freckles away we should be doing like
this kind of stuff
these are my college days
Civil War jewel is close to me in 20
years once we have his character we're
gonna go into our first day of shooting
and this is all the interview stuff this
is a lot of the setup for this story
here have you done mocap before no never
oh really okay first time okay so well
hopefully it's a good experience my soul
will be sucked into the machine I can't
wait we're taking precise measurements
of Joel so that way the proportions of
his motion capture skeleton accurately
reflect his body sometimes we all wish
we could escape the real world for a
while and go somewhere fantasy right now
we're capturing uh seven different
exposures of this lighting system so we
can make a high dynamic range 360
lighting array that will just again
further speed up this process we want to
be as rapid as we can we have our script
we have our basic beats but it's really
up to Joel to kind of bring his own
comedy to it and do what he does best hi
I'm Joel I've been a professional
digital double for 20 years now when
Digimon came out imagine how I felt
digital monster kids would come up on
the street and try to suck me into their
cyber or what I don't I don't know
Digimon that well but they tried to suck
me into something and you can imagine a
house here you can't make a scorpion man
king without CGI without me I mean you
know what they say God made Man In His
Image and we were made after man so
we're Two Steps From God that's pretty
good how many steps from God as a dog
many other than the reversing the
letters but that's different people see
a dog and they're like oh a dog I love
dogs you know how many times people have
seen me and done that
you know you had Lawnmower Man Lawnmower
Man 2 Bicentennial men all sorts of men
you do remember
um the abyss the Water Guy
that was my dad
we need to know what our edit looks like
before we have any idea of how many VFX
shots we have so this whole thing was
meant to be like a three minute piece
and we thought it would actually get a
bit tighter in the course of editing but
actually the opposite happened once we
got Joel on set and filmed with them
it's like the dude has so much to give
comedically he's able to Riff on
everything and like the only way to make
it work was to let it breathe a little
bit more and because of that and that
means we have about eight more minutes
worth of VFX shots to do so
that's a little bit of a wrench but I
think we can do it so now that I have
the edit locked here I need to prep
everything for Sam to do his final
unreal render passes take by take go
through and isolate all the moments that
we actually use in the edit that we're
seeing Joel and I'm going to just
isolate the audio for that moment right
so I'm going to export them the whole
take it's a whole five minute take but
the only audio that's going to be in
there is just the moments Joel's talking
put in some sync sounds for him so it's
like
you get a Digi double in a movie in the
90s and then I'm going to export that
whole take because you've isolated the
parts where he's talking it makes the
process really simple like in fact like
having that waveform it eliminates
having to clean up every second of
footage that we you know captured right
now we have a mega human in a chair and
he's talking and it's working really
well in fact is this is a very easy part
of the process unlike the actual
animation for the body The Face
animation has to be basically streamed
into Unreal Engine that's it's kind of a
weird thing we're going to start over in
iclone Nick has prepped these audio
files so you drag a little audio clip
into it hit generate text and the
computer goes through the audio file and
converts all the speech waveforms into
text which you can then use that to
animate the mouth because it is able to
break the words down and understand the
mouth shape it's supposed to be making
at every part of the sentence it's
incredible how accurate is this normally
uh it's like 60 or 70 accurate sometimes
you get garbage and gibberish but all I
got to do is go through and just double
check it so and apply boom people love
it we think that went great that went
great and we have a talking style editor
here just gonna 200 everything so it's
really clear because he's so low poly
all the expressions are so muted like
keeping getting the mouth Motions like
huge really helps so there's one last
thing everything else on the face and
that one's super easy basically I like
to just cover it all up with a quick
foam capture pass here open up the live
face app from reillusion
I basically do a facial performance pass
on top of the lip sync
I hear words like disgusting
disturbing
that's it I hear words like disgusting
disturbing perfect safe final stage to
sync that back with the body it's really
easy since we're using this audio track
in unreal two I'm just gonna smack a
hard face keyframe on here so on the
third beat we do like a wacky expression
when I see that face that pop I know to
sink into that beep now it's going to be
synced to the body so into unreal looks
like everything's linked up here from
iclone so basically I just start
recording over here and I have an icon
here and I
play
I hear words like disgusting disturbing
uncanny
it looks good man that's it now it's in
unreal we can combine it with our body
data and hit render so I'm currently
underway simulating away uh Joel's
little lymph body falling down this set
of stairs and that's actually the
perfect segue for this video's sponsor
of polycam for those of you who don't
know I actually used to be a visual
effects supervisor on set I used to do
like TV music videos all that fun stuff
there's a few tools that I insist on
bringing to set because I find them to
be absolutely essential for the back end
work and one of those is polycam for
instance with this shot of Joel falling
down the stairs I would need to recreate
the stairs making sure there's the right
set of stairs that they're the right
height the right length all this stuff
that I would have to take measurements
for but now thanks to polycam I can
light our scan on my phone and get this
done in a hundredth of the time you can
line it up to your footage very very
quickly and you have perfectly accurate
Collision geometry perfectly accurate
reflective geometry that you're going to
pick up in any of your shiny objects it
is an absolute Game Changer go to
polydot cam and use our code crew22 to
get 20 off polycam Pro for a whole year
polycam is available in both IOS and
Android but you must redeem this code on
the web this offers good until the end
of the year so maybe consider giving the
gift of polycam this holiday season and
with that let's get back to violently
punishing the digital version of Joel
Haver
so while Sam is busy uh handling all the
interview stuff finno and I we are over
here bringing all of Joel's stunts to
life in a more traditional VFX Pipeline
and a perfect illustration of all of
this is actually the first shot right
this is in a way the most important shot
because we're being introduced to the
character of Joel as a ragdoll Digi
devil it's very crucial that we nail
this one right out the gate because it's
setting the tone for the entire short
you think about a ragdoll simulation and
you think about filming a plate for that
how do you cover it how do you know what
he's going to hit and what he's going to
bounce off you don't it's important that
you open up the flexibility our approach
to doing that was to First create a
super high resolution Panorama of our
entire scene because then we can project
that in 3D space create a CG camera and
pan and tilt wherever we need to it's
total flexibility so boom once we have
our panorama on set it's also important
to get a couple other assets for the
back end the most essential being the
360 of the lighting of that space that
way we can recreate lighting very
quickly and easily and the other is
using polycam to get a lidar scan you
are getting perfectly replicated
geometry with scale information built in
and Tech textures built in so now what
we have is real accurate Collision
geometry and from there it's a matter of
recreating the garbage can so that he
has something to collide with and
something to fall into and then the
juicy part rebuilding our beloved Boy
Sam has this meta human this low poly
monstrosity that he sends to us we
rebuild him in post actually creating
the Ragdoll we gotta give that boy his
bones and once we have that done we get
down to the funnest part to me the
simulations right we're just throwing
this guy off the bridge at the end of
the day when you're simulating it's it's
complete chance and it took me about
three hours of iteration to finally get
him to flip hit the wall with his face
drop onto the trash can and literally
fold over almost hit and then drop in
the trash can it was about 300 percent
better than any Sim I'd got to that
point and the only reason you get there
is because you iterate and once you have
that simulation done then you add the
cloth and since we have a finished
simulation cast as long as that starting
frame has the clothes where they're
supposed to be those clothes will follow
him on his already estab simulation and
then once the actual Sim and render is
complete you know where this shot's
going
he's going to that guy so from Houdini
Jalen has rendered out all these
different aov passes that allow us to
comp our digidouble of Joel into the
scene we have here our Standalone Jewel
render and we have our Standalone
background render to integrate Joel into
the scene we go through a few different
steps of basically matching its color
values to the scene making sure our
shadow is integrated into the
environment there so we can see there's
a little bit of Shadow he's casting on
the wall it feels weird if you don't
have that in there and as he gets closer
or actually impacts the wall that is
going to get darker from there we have a
simple stencil that we're using to kind
of mask him falling in to the garbage
can honestly a pretty simple comp setup
but simple doesn't mean bad so this here
is our final shot and feels like a dude
just got kicked off a bridge and
I don't know man it makes me laugh every
time
he was born to do this dude that's some
hot stuff he was born to do this that's
the new tick tock dance dude did you
tell that [ __ ] the squeak cake that's a
good kid but yeah man this uh this
workflow going from Houdini to Nuke and
doing all your amazing ragdolls and
costumes working really well for us it's
a marriage made in heaven I'll tell you
do the squid kid
I'm voting squid kid 2024. okay look
we're at the final stretch here we're
all sitting down to watch through the
cut Sam went in spiced up some of the
angles we're like so close to hitting
export on this thing it's been a lot of
work to get to this point so we would
really appreciate it if you go over to
Corridor right now watch the short let
us know what you thought obviously a
huge thank you to Joel Haver for
bringing his skills over to Corridor uh
check out his channel he's absolutely
hilarious his sketch comedy is top tier
and it's definitely worth a subscription
quarter channel is really close to 10
million go subscribe to it yeah if you
subscribe and you get us to 10 million
we get a button that's different than
the button we have right now